All right. All right. So if you're wondering today,
we are shaving this beautiful head.
I'm not prepared at all for this video.
I just saw you sitting here in my makeup chair and was like, Hey,
let's shave your head for you too. So I actually,
and it's so random because guys, this is not planned.
I brought up a pot with me for a whole other video,
and now I'm just going to use it to shave out him. And you ran out of razors.
So we're going to use my razor because I wasn't prepared for this video at all.
And it's, it's new.
It's new. It's a new razor. Cause mine was very like, the blade was super doll.
And I was like, if we shoot this, we need a good razor.
So can we go get the shaving cream? I'll look at this. Actually.
I'm super excited about this because now I don't have to do it.
I usually shave in the shower. So you use just shampoo?
No, you have shaving cream.
So we're using, um, feminine products on Yohanas, which is,
I want to see it. Oh my God. This looks awesome.
Move it around. It's really good. All right. Ready?
This is so funny. You must, you must, you must, you must,
you must have so much fun shaving every day. What's it like to be involved?
So, first of all, it's not a lot of fun, cause it takes up a lot of time. Um,
like I said, I really enjoy this right now because I don't have to do it.
And it's always, it sounds weird, but you know, when somebody, I mean, not like,
you know, cuts your hair, like gives you a massage, gives you a massage,
whatever. Um, it's always better if someone else does it. So right now this,
this feels good. Ooh. I get a head massage too.
The best makeup artists always massage your face before.
Technically this is like a part of your face, right?
A beautiful face needs a lot of space.
Goodness. It's actually really
cook dinner. Ooh. You know what?
I should do put a robot, you know,
just in case, uh, the monetization gods are like, Hey.
You're wearing a sports bra. This should be
before you start, have you done this before? Yeah. Yeah.
You need to shave sewer way past due for this buddy.
Oh my gosh.
Just even that sounds so good against the grain right.
That I would do later. I would just go like back first.
Cause the hair grows down. So it's like easy to shave this way.
A lot of guys try to do it like down first, but for me,
I don't know, like this is the long for me right now.
Like usually I shave it way before that stage.
Libraries. Yeah. I know. I hope I've been focused.
All right. So this is getting in the top of the head.
It's not the best to razor for this, but Oh my gosh.
It's so satisfying though.
This part, like the top part is easy. Um,
the hard part is the back because first of all, I don't see it.
And there's more hair on the back, like in the top. It's where it's receding.
So it's, it's easier.
But the back is just, it's annoying. Cause you, you have, um,
the bones out of your skull. So it's like a little, or at least I have that.
I don't know if everybody I'm pretty sure everybody has those, you know? Right.
Oh yeah. Bumps. We got them.
Dave around them is pretty tough. Especially with no eyes like,
Oh no, I don't want to do that.
I'm British here within the next couple of years,
I will lose all of my hair and then I don't have, [inaudible] important.
You guys be embarrassed if they have no hair.
Just rock it. But good. This,
I have a beautiful girl woman right next to me shaving my head.
I'm just afraid. I'm going to get your eyebrows.
Oh yeah, don't do that. I need those. I need some hair in my face.
That's why we have be exactly.
Oh my gosh. Just the back. You guys going to love the back part.
I really hope I'm focused. I have no idea. But do you want to check? It's not
my channel.
So to answer your question, should people or guys be embarrassed about, um,
you know, being involved? That's a super common thing and we, uh,
like I share this with you all the time.
Cause I get a lot of DMS from guys and I try to respond to every single one of
them. Um, when they start losing their hair, they get,
I don't want to say insecure, but like I think that's, that's the word, right?
Like just insecure.
Like they did lose their self-confidence and then wear hats all the time.
I mean, I like wearing hats too, but not because I'm ashamed of not having hair,
just like it. But yeah, some guys do that to cover up, you know,
not having hair, but there's absolutely no need for that.
It's just hair that has nothing to do with your personality.
It has nothing to do with it.
It was all from a girl's perspective because the guy telling us other guys,
it's kind of like, it's cool,
but they really want to know what the ladies thing. Cause a lot of times are,
you know, actually some other guys want to know what other guys think too.
So it's good to hear it from both of us.
But what I will say is I think
it's sexy.
You're actually the only bald guy I've ever I've ever dated.
You even had
[inaudible] we have a baby, it'll come out
low maintenance guys. We're not the cutest ball baby.
And then we'll start the channel.
What's our problem. Maybe I'll shave my head too. We actually have a video.
I'll put at the end of this video of me bald with your harness that exists.
And that perform very well. But the acting was really good though, too.
Two, two, this is taking a, why should I even edit this?
Or should I just leave this raw and just upload it straight question.
How low do I go for the site?
Oh, you go, you can go like where my ear is.
Like I don't see it. So I'll trust you.
I feel like I want to shape you.
You know how the barbers like have those spine razors and they're like,
we gotta get that guys, if you know of any good racers,
like that comment below second start, like I know they're super dangerous.
Um, cause they're so sharp. Uh, but it would be fun.
What is this called again?
The barbershop Jeff's barbershop.
Straightforward. I like it. When did you decide to commit? Yeah.
I don't have the answer. Do you know when it was? I remember where it was.
It was a six and a hundred, three years ago.
I remember it was in that tiny little room with a security guard, yelled at us.
He was like, there's no filming in here. Sony 4k,
whatever cyber shop. What was the camera? Like? Super tiny. Yeah.
Um, how clean that is. And he was like, you're not allowed to film in air.
When I went to, um, the military military service in Austria. I did it too.
You've been there, done that. Yeah, exactly.
Strong military men do it.
So if anybody out there is experiencing hair loss or whatever and you decide to
shave your head,
like I need to shift everything the first week is going to feel and look just,
everything's going to be super weird because you will feel the wind on your head
and around your ears because you don't have any hair anymore. Um,
and just looking in the mirror, it's going to be like, Whoa, that's weird.
Or taking a shower is interesting. Cause you want to go through your hair,
but it's not there anymore.
So all of that was like the first week or like the first two
weeks was there's so many experiences, so many like not emotions,
which is like feelings. It was awesome. Um, and then I loved it.
You know what I mean? So many emotions. It was, it was cool because it's like,
it's new. It's like a new haircut. It's I mean, I know it's no hair,
but like I think it's sounds funny, but it it's it's considered.
A haircut, right? Or no, it was cool.
So much work the labor and I want this to be, Oh my gosh. It's like,
this is weird. It looks like, like fibers.
It looks like those magnetic, like fluffy fibers there's toys.
Trust me with my sword. Yeah. Can we do it quick?
So yeah, this isn't going to be a daily thing though. It just
[inaudible] I'll do it once a week. Ooh, what was okay. This is like,
you know what the hell you're going to make up a number,
a million views. Okay baby. Yeah, that's doable.
I get like 20 million on some. It's been a while.
Okay. Give me a break. I haven't posted on YouTube in forever.
And now you guys,
your comments asking me to and asking me for different videos is
super motivating. So thank you. And now I'm posting again.
Okay. How about a hundred thousand views? 15,000 comments?
No. 15,000 legs. Sorry.
A hundred thousand views on what timeframe in a week?
No, no.
Let's do 500,000 views in a week. Okay
then shaming your own head buddy. If it gets 500,000 views,
I didn't get that service once a week deal.
Nice guys. Make sure.
Make sure to share this video with all of your friends posted everywhere you
can. Don't I'm hoping for no views on this video time,
time is money.
That's also why I'm like doing these types of videos for you guys too.
Cause they're super like fun and easy to do.
And also like with everything else going on,
it makes it so I can be consistent and actually doing the things that I really
do in my everyday life. Like Johann has had to shave set. And this happens,
like I helped you on us, out with the back of a set a lot. Um,
but you do pretty good on your end. I don't know what's going on here. Oh,
this Oh, that's already shaved. That's weird. It's just sticking to your head.
Oh wow. Okay. I was wondering why it wasn't going away spoliation. Oh my gosh.
This must be great exposure creation. All right.
So doing a little bit more.
We're going to finish this baby off of us to a shaving cream again.
I do laundry too. Okay.
There we go. Hello, Mr. White.
So I'm doing the neck now and then get those
straggle Lees over. Get yourself a girl. That'll shave your head.
So almost you good? Yep. Yeah.
The first time I shaved your harnesses head was for I'm an Instagram skit.
He told me to buzz it right off, but little did I know he wanted to shave it.
Anyway. I liked that though.
I like accepting I'm losing my hair and instead of trying to hide it,
just shaving it off confidence. And a man is like one of the sexiest things.
Not like cocky. Don't confuse it. Just like confident,
good and secure with himself behind the gear and make sure you clean behind your
ears guys. A lot of guys don't and it skirts.
I discovered that I was checking behind all these guys. I'm like,
let me see behind your ears. 95% was unbelievable.
Dirty years. I'm going to put some oil on after two.
It's a long day surname for every day. Oh my gosh. She's a mess.
Look in the shnazzy here
you look good. That's up here.
I love her as water Rose Wall.
Wow. If that's not a nice looking head,
I don't know what is,
Oh my gosh. It's so shiny. Wow baby.
It's so shiny and beautiful.
Now that is a sexy man with a sexy bald head and
I love it. Oh my gosh. It's so smooth. Thank you guys for watching.
You can do. Oh, we need some beard oil too. Okay. Awesome.
You want to do the sign off?
Yes. Thank you so much for watching guys.
Don't forget to hit the notification button up there and leave a comment and
like let them in and know what you want to see next. If you want to see. Oh,
and don't forget it. Share this with video with everybody.
We need 500,000 views so I can get my head shaven every week.
It's like the VIP treatment. Hi guys. Thanks for watching.
[inaudible].